okay so last night was the collider
screening of Avengers infinity war at
arc like cinema and the QA with the
Russo brothers immediately following
they made it really really fun for
everybody and my buddy I'm a film editor
actually answered the first question
right and one an Infinity Gauntlet and
he even got to meet the Russo brothers
so huge shout-out to him for keeping me
and everybody else updated on everything
that was happening at the event be sure
to follow him for updates on his editing
and he also has a short film coming out
pretty soon called Fair Play he did get
to talk to the Russo brothers and did
ask them about the trailer and I'll get
into that in just a little bit so right
off the bat we got a ton of information
about Avengers infinity war there were
some big questions that a lot of people
had after the movie came out and the
researchers did a great job at answering
all of the questions I'm gonna talk
about all the questions that were asked
and all the answers that they gave all
the new information that we learned
because it's actually all really really
interesting there was talks of Secret
Wars there was talks of beta ray bill
there was talks about the soulstone just
a lot of great exciting information but
I know everybody just wants to hear
about Avengers 4 so I'll do you a favor
since this probably is going to be a
long video and I'll talk about that
first so right off the bat sadly there
was no trailer shown yesterday it wasn't
released anywhere and it wasn't shown at
the screening I know there were some
radio stations claiming that the
Avengers 4 trailer was coming out
yesterday or today those are false so
don't expect the trailer today also
nobody knows what the title is yet at
least officially there are many people
out there that stick to annihilation
like it's carved in stone and it very
well may be but last night the title was
not revealed and nobody from Marvel or
the Russo brothers have confirmed any
title at all in fact when the QA started
the Russo brothers said no Avengers 4
and no Avengers 4 trailer questions and
obviously everybody was pretty bummed
out because there was hope that we would
get some information about Avengers for
either the trailer release date or the
title but when anybody asked a question
about Avengers 4 despite them saying no
questions
here's what they did that's right they
brought an air horn so anytime somebody
asked a question about Avengers 4 they
blew the air horn
they even teased about this on their
Instagram story so nothing official came
from Marvel or the Russo brothers last
night but when people got the chance to
talk to the Russo brothers they did say
that the trailer is coming very soon so
that could be in a few days or that
could be in a month since Kevin Feige
said that we'd get it before the end of
the year at the end of this video I'll
talk about the current speculation after
last night on what the trailer release
date could be but again that is just
speculation and nothing official but
like I said there were many great
questions asked and the answers gave us
a lot of great insight so I'll just dive
into the QA also if you'd like a chance
to win a copy of Infinity Ward the art
of the movie art book a copy of Infinity
Ward Deadpool 2 or ant-man and the wasp
bomb blu-ray and some special edition
posters all you have to do is subscribe
to my channel like the video and comment
down below with your thoughts and your
favorite superhero so the first question
I'll talk about is about Secret Wars
I've actually seen some people already
say that Secret Wars is confirmed to be
happening not true here's a clip of the
question and what the Russo brothers
answered
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
so as you heard the Russo brothers are
taking a break from directing superhero
films but since Disney is about to get
the Fantastic Four and x-men they were
asked if they would come back and they
replied not unless there's going to be a
Secret Avengers film so that is super
exciting that that could be a
possibility and the Russo brothers would
obviously be amazing at directing that
film but this in no way confirms that
there's one in the works right now the
next question was about Red Skull and
why the Russo brothers decided to bring
him back for Avengers infinity war and
this is what they had to say this just
makes perfect sense the Russo brothers
wanted a character that the audience
could trust and believe when it came
down to how to obtain the stones
apparently there was talk of Jessica
Jones or maybe iron fist but again
ultimately it came down to who can the
audience trust and since red skull has a
history of the tesseract we all know we
can trust Red Skull the next question
was about the supposed Captain Marvel
Easter egg in Avengers infinity war with
coal obsidian sash that looks a lot like
Captain Marvel's outfit well Anthony
Russo said that coal obsidians Captain
Marvel looking sash was just a
coincidence
then somebody asked the question kind of
about vision possibly coming back in
Avengers 4 in which the Russo brothers
replied vision is dead somebody then
asked a question of why the Russo
brothers started the movie off with
feyo's destroying Thor ship and here's
what they had to say the word the
Avengers were broken and separated and
so the fact that be honest is spread
fast and he wants to head was even more
threatening to that narrative in order
for von Drago be waiting it out thank
you and wish you know he never actually
did so in ever RNA and that was part an
aspect of having panels ones that had
[Music]
so the shock of just how strong and
smart
Thanos is the ability for Thanos to be
one step ahead of the Avengers and have
the upper hand while the Avengers are
broken and separated is why they started
the movie off with phantoms
they wanted to show you who he is and
just how strong of a villain he is then
the Russo brothers set some Theory
straight about where fan OHS is at the
end of infinity war many people had
different theories and ideas about where
he could be some people thought he was
on earth but some people thought that he
was actually on Titan and that he used
the time stone to simply reverse the
effects of the planet dying or he simply
went back in time
well the rooster brothers confirmed that
he is not on Titan he is on what they
called Titan 2 basically his new home
because they said that the planet that
he's on is not Titan in the past another
question that was asked was how did they
decide which heroes were going to fall
victim of the snap and what they said
was they always knew who they wanted
dusted so they came into the movie
knowing who was going to fall victim and
it sure was a coincidence that all of
the original Avengers are the ones who
are left we see what you did there Russo
brothers and speaking about heroes that
were dusted they were asked that if they
could bring one hero back that fell
victim to the snap who would it be and
their answer was Peter Parker
I don't feel so good
you're alright I don't know I don't know
what's happening I don't want to go no
want to go it's air please
and speaking about Spidey the
researchers were asked about spider-man
homecoming where it says that the events
of spider-man homecoming took place
eight years later when in fact we all
know that they took place four years
later after the events of New York and
not eight when asked about this the
Russo brothers said that they didn't
make spider-man homecoming and their
film is right
confirming that the events of spider-man
homecoming took place four years after
the events of New York and not eight you
may have heard stories that Disney is
developing a Falcon and Winter Soldier
TV series for that Disney streaming
service Disney Plus and somebody asked
the Russo brothers if they're involved
in it and they said that if it's
happening they're not involved in it now
that doesn't mean that it's not
happening but if it does they won't be
involved somebody asked that if the
firing of James Gunn and the hold put on
guardians of the galaxy three affected
Avengers four like some rumor said it
did
there were many rumors that the firing
of James Gunn and the hold on guardians
of the galaxy three made the Russo
brothers change of vengers for the Russo
brothers said that when all of this
happened they had already shot the movie
so it didn't affect Avengers 4 at all
the Russo brothers also addressed the
fake scripts and the fake scenes that
they did and they actually gave an
example one example was in one scene
they actually had Gamora throw Thanos
off of a cliff which obviously never
happened Thanos threw Gamora off as a
sacrifice to get the soul stone but
speaking of Gamora and Thanos somebody
asked about a possible mistake that the
Russo brothers could have made and
guardians of the galaxy Gamora says that
she was the last of her race but an
infinity war Thanos says that her planet
is thriving and that the children eat
well after he balanced it as it turns
out it's not a mistake but the Russo
brothers replied with who do you believe
Thanos or Gamora
so perhaps Thanos's line also bad news
for Asgardian fans the reefs are others
confirmed that half of the Asgardians
that were on thor ship got away from
Thanos but as it turns out half of the
half were wiped away by Thanos a snap
the researchers were also asked about
beta ray bill and as it turns out they
said that they discussed him as a
possible character several times but
ultimately they could never work him
into the story we were so close y'all
then we got some major soulstone
questions answered when asked about the
soulstone the ruse
brother said that the soulstone has the
ability to manipulate your soul and your
essence of who you are
Thanos uses the soul stone to pull
strange out of his own body when he's
multiple strangers Santos also uses the
soul stone to talk to his dead daughter
I don't know about you all but I have a
hunch that we might see soul world and
Avengers for the Russo brothers also
addressed in the Q&A some theories about
the Hulk fighting Thanos a lot of people
said that famous was easily able to
defeat the Hulk because he was using the
Power Stone but this is not true
according to the Russo brothers Thanos
was able to easily beat the Hulk in the
beginning not because of the Power Stone
but rather because he was smarter and
more calculated than the Hulk and
another theory that came up in regards
to this scene was that Loki disguised
himself as banner in order to escape
well they set the story straight and
said that this is not true in their
definitive words they said Loki is dead
and I thought I would end this breakdown
of the qat with Stanley the Russo
brothers were asked about Stanley's
cameos and they said that Stanley was
always told about his particular cameo
right before he came to the set and
never turned down any of their cameos
Stanley had a running joke on the set
that was why do I always only get one
line Stanley has in fact shot his cameo
for Avengers 4 so we will see him there
so that's it for this breakdown of the
Russo brothers Q&A with Collider the
questions that I discussed were ones
that I found most relevant to infinity
war in Avengers 4 the qat was two hours
long so there were some questions that
were asked that I didn't put in here
like what was the Russo brothers
favorite part of the movie Thor landing
in Wakanda by the way
[Music]
[Music]
but again these were the most important
and relevant questions and answers again
unfortunately nothing official was given
to us about a vendor's for Avengers for
trailer or the Avengers for title but
the Russo brothers did say that it is
coming very soon and according to the
reports of some people that actually got
to meet and talk to the Russo brothers
have confirmed this that they did say
it's coming very very soon so again I
know I've said this before but the
prelude comes out December 5th and they
should release the trailer before then
and the rumor going around right now by
people who were at the event and by
people who have been right about these
things in the past is that it will come
out December 3rd it's important to note
that although this is being talked about
by credible people it is no way
confirmed but we can only hope so let me
know what you think about the Russo
brothers answers and the Q&A in the
comments down below and don't forget to
subscribe to my channel comment down
below and like the video so you can
enter the giveaway and stay up to date
on everything relating to Avengers 4 as
always thank you all so much for
watching Wolf Wolf
[Music]
you